this is gone long enough this guy spins
off weeks no calls no texts no social
media nothing
we need a new top five this week you to
think of something I've even thought of
that Hummer glad you could join us
Wow there is a lot to unpack here Ayanna
Walter and I were just talking about
superheroes remember when we used to
talk about comic books every week well
we talked about things vaguely related
to comic books yeah what if we did a
comic book theme top-five episode now
that Walters back I need to know that
you know this isn't actually Walter yeah
Heather I know I built it this is the
form my grief is taking thank goodness
so what do you think I think it's a
little weird but there are less healthy
ways for you to deal with your green oh
no silly I meant the comic theme top
five episode oh yeah sure it'll take us
back to our channel awesome roots what
kind of thing were you thinking of well
maybe we I'm sorry what was that Walter
hmm Walter says here are the top five
worst comic book movie casting oh boy
number five Jesse Eisenberg as Lex
Luthor this is probably one of the most
divisive choices on our list Jesse
Eisenberg played Lex Luthor in the movie
Batman V Superman from the moment this
casting was announced there was doubt
that Eisenberg could play the character
well there is of course the physical
difference Lex Luthor in the comics is
more burly and threatening he's a
cunning aggressive businessman who is
overly confident in pompous Eisenberg
plays the character as an awkward young
internet mogul who people can't even
stand to be around and of course the
hair traditionally the character is bald
now before you get too mad commenters
yes we realize that Eisenberg is
supposedly playing Lex Luthor jr. who
was a totally different character maybe
my father named the company after
himself he was the Lex in front of the
court are you doing which is also a
problem with how the character is
portrayed is he actually Lex Luthor or a
new and different character why is it
necessary for us to have to ask this
question perhaps the worst part of
Eisenberg's performance is some of the
quirks and tics that he adds I
understand that he's trying to create a
character but most of it comes off as
way over the top he's trying too hard to
be crazy veering into Riddler or even
Joker territory he makes choices that
show insanity but are also painfully
predictable who could ever forget that
cherry Jolly Rancher scene
[Music]
it's cherry
so wrong number for Jennifer Garner as
Elektra we know Jennifer Garner is
capable of holding her own during a
fight sequence but there were some
questionable choices of Elektra from her
introduction in daredevil yet somehow
she managed to contractually earn her
own spin-off where they get mildly
weirder
oh my god someone get this lady a hair
tie the inconsistency of her plot
dependent flashbacks make me seasick
ranging from her childhood to something
that happened moments ago
she's also given the ability to briefly
see into the future now I guess
for some reason the writers felt it
necessary that she have OCD - none of
those characteristics belong to Elektra
Elektra is supposed to be an extremely
well honed assassin but the premonitions
and implausible accuracy turned her from
athletic to full-on mutant number three
Topher Grace as venom after the success
of the first Sam Raimi spider-man fans
were begging to see when a spider-man's
most popular villains venom on the big
screen and finally in spider-man 3 they
got their wish just kidding the October
grace
much like Eisenberg and Lex Luthor
Topher Grace looked nothing like any
venom or Eddie Brock we had ever seen
before Eddie is a big almost jock type
Topher Grace is a wormy little loser in
this movie venom is one of spider-man's
most intimidating villains no one is
scared of Eric Foreman oh my spider
sense is tingling if you know what I'm
talking about keep up with a smart mouth
and my foot will be nine-tenths of the
way up your ass
of course I'm not saying that every
character in a movie needs to look
exactly like their comic are animated
equivalent it can be good to get a
refreshing new look at a character but
this wasn't fresh at all sometimes when
you're pulling from an already
established mythos and don't try to tell
me comics do not have a mythos there are
certain things that fans expect to see a
certain way what's next vampires that
sparkle in the Sun part of the problem
with Venom's appearance in this movie is
Sam Raimi didn't even want him there
were other villains that he was fighting
for screen time against this left him
underdeveloped and his motivations murky
all these years later and I'm still not
convinced they know what they're doing
after that first venom solo movie
trailer hum Hardy is a much better
choice than Topher Grace though here's
to hoping they get it right this time
number two Alicia Silverstone as Batgirl
please be looking for me uncle Alfred
meet Barbara Wilson nice - Alfred
Pennyworth what why second thing and I'm
already curious Batman you take it from
here
you are Batgirl Oh yikes it got worse as
much as we loved Silverstone in clueless
Babs should be anything but there's a
lot of telling us she's smart not a
whole lot of showing I'm on break from
Oxbridge Academy
Alfred's all my mother the new Computer
Sciences Division how'd you know it says
on the patch on your sweater I will
argue until I'm blue in the face that
Batman and Robin was worth it for some
really cool vehicles and gadgets but who
throws away a bat cowl maybe you melted
the least you can do is bring some cool
action sequences in that bat suit or
just walk back where it's that works too
[Music]
and the number one worst comic book
movie casting is Shaq in steel the year
was 1997 Batman Forever had done well in
space Jim was popular combining the two
seemed like a guaranteed payout
it wasn't steel stars basketball
superstar Shaquille O'Neal as John Henry
irons a man who builds a super suit out
of steel to fight some crime and combat
some super weapons although Shaq had
done two movies prior to steel he didn't
consider himself an actor and rightfully
so he struggles through this whole movie
looking totally awkward and even
uncomfortable at times there is
literally a scene where guy shoots his
junk and Shaq's response is to just
waggle his finger
[Music]
speaking of waggling look at those
eyebrows go even the basketball jokes
and references fell flat never kill
individuals oh he always misses those
the action was also lacking this was
partly because it was almost impossible
to get a stunt double for Shaq due to
his height it would be way too obvious
it wasn't him he moves slowly through
action sequences making them dull that
suit wasn't doing him any favors either
it looks cumbersome certain facial
expressions would reveal that it
definitely wasn't made of steel overall
this whole movie is considered one of
the worst superhero films ever made with
the bad acting writing and effects it's
hard to disagree let us know your least
favorite comic book movie castings in
the comments down below what would you
like to see us cover next on the show
keep using hashtag where's Walter to
send us your theories about where Walter
went she didn't mean that Walter you can
find me on Twitter at Heather ruse
Instagram @h ruse or twitch twitch.tv
slash how their roofs and you can find
me on Facebook as I Anna Wade and
everywhere else as awesome Ayanna we'll
catch you on the next page
awesome comics isn't coming back
[Music]
oh hey Jim I'm headed out for the day
okay well see you later did you hear
that what is that
[Music]
Hey
what are you doing you didn't see that
or hear it see what there's something
creepy going on with this door I'm not
crazy
go home
you
[Music]